representative Ilhan Omar laughs it up
as a fake anti-semitism resolution
passes the house the media of course
tried to blame Republicans for
anti-semitism and we checked the mailbag
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]
I've rarely seen a moment as outrageous
as this moment in American politics and
I don't mean outrageous as in hilarious
or outstanding I mean outrageous as in
we should all be outraged if you have a
shred of morality left in your body
looking at how the Democrats are acting
looking at how the media are acting it
is truly astonishing we get to all that
in just one second first let's talk
about saving money on your legal bills
at your business there are five things
business owners can count on from
LegalZoom first reliability over two
million people have used Legal Zoom to
start their businesses second experience
they've been helping all types of
business owners for over 17 years you
can count on Legal Zoom to help with all
the details I personally been using
Legal Zoom for years I am a lawyer and
they have great legal resources number 3
helpful support they've the right people
standing by ready for your questions all
based in the United States number for
legal advice Legal Zoom is not a law
firm but they have a network of
independent attorneys licensed in all 50
states they can help you review
contracts help with employment laws
advise you on many of the hurdles that
pop up when you're running a business
and finally number 5 no surprises Legal
Zoom provides complete transparency with
upfront pricing customer reviews and a
satisfaction guarantee check out Legal
Zoom today see how they can make life
better for you and your business and
don't forget to enter Ben at checkout to
save even more Legal Zoom is where life
meets legal legalzoom.com don't forget
to enter Ben at checkout to save even
more legalzoom.com where life meets
legal go check them out right now so we
begin today with this ridiculous stupid
foolhardy obviously obfuscate ory
resolution from the House Democrats that
was set to condemn I kid you not racism
and bigotry against and the direct quote
african-americans Latinos Native
Americans Asian Americans and Pacific
Islanders and other people of color Jews
Muslims Hindus Sikhs the LGBTQ community
immigrants and others with verbal
attacks incitement and violence so Jews
come in I believe 7th on that list of
peoples who are who are protected under
this resolution and the resolution
specifically calls out the effect of
white supremacy white supremacist
anti-semitism among other among other
things that are targeted by white
supremacists other groups targeted by
white supremacist let's remember this
resolution that was sponsored and
house yesterday and passed
overwhelmingly was a direct response to
representative Ilhan Omar Democrat of
Minnesota who is an open anti-semite who
has apologized some three times in the
last six weeks or quasi apologized or
not apologized for three separate openly
anti-semitic statements one she
suggested that Israel the Jews had
hypnotized the world with their Jew
powers second that Jewish money lay
behind American support for Israel and
third that American supporters of Israel
were in fact boiled to Israel itself and
so those are all three anti-semitic
statements not one of them has to do
with Israeli policy so what are the
Democrats do first they remove Ilhan
Omar's name from an anti-semitism
resolution then they say you know what
we can't condemn anti-semitism because
people might read between the lines and
see we're talking about oh hi Omar so
instead what we will do is we'll condemn
all bad things and then just to make
sure that we obfuscate the rationale for
this whole thing we'll talk about white
supremacy as though that's the issue of
the last six weeks now recall there was
a House Resolution passed against white
supremacy in January it was voted for
unanimously in the house so this is
nothing new the only thing that is new
here is that Democrats are openly
pandering on behalf of Ilhan Omar they
decided that they were it was more
important to green-light anti-semitism
from members of their intersectional
base than it was for them to condemn
anti-semitism it is in fact that simple
it is that easy it has a seven page
resolution that is filled with all sorts
of randomness specifically in order to
avoid talking about Ilhan Omar that's
all this was so this thing passes
overwhelmingly because Democrats are
passing something that is quote-unquote
unobjectionable but there are some
people on the right who don't vote for
it why because they say openly we're not
voting for this thing because it's an
open and obvious attempt to obfuscate
the actual issue here which is the
anti-semitism of a member of the House
who is not even being removed from the
Foreign Affairs Committee and and so how
does the media react to that they say oh
look Republicans are Pro anti-semitism
I'll explain how all this works so let's
begin with the various players talking
about this idiotic resolution which is
designed to again cover for Ilhan Omar's
anti-semitism that is the only reason
that this resolution
came to the floor and it's the only
reason it is this broad contending all
the things so here's Nancy Pelosi
yesterday talking about the resolution
right before its passage I don't I don't
think that that the congresswoman is
perhaps appreciate the point date of how
is heard by other people although I
don't believe it was intended and an
anti-semitic way we're working on
something it was one resolution
addressing these these forms of hatred
not mentioning her name because it's not
about her it's about Pelosi explicitly
says it's not about her except for how
this whole thing is about her this whole
thing is about L hen Omar the only
reason we're having this discussion is
because she keeps saying anti-semitic
stuff because she knows what she is
saying and she doesn't care because
she's an anti-semite but Pelosi openly
acknowledges that this resolution is
designed to avoid talking about all of
this
representative Ted Deutsch may be the
only honest Democrat left in the
Democratic caucus he gets up on the
floor of the house and he talks about
how the resolution really should only
address anti-semitism but his fellow
Democrats are too gutless to do that
this is not political no one should make
it political the use of anti-semitic
language and images can never be
tolerated what's been so difficult for
so many people in my community is that
people who are fearful when anti-semitic
tropes are used are being told that
they're wrong when a colleague invokes
classic anti-semitic
lies three times then this body must
condemn that anti-semitism anti-semitism
is worthy of being taken seriously on
its own it's worthy of being singularly
called out words matter for generations
they have had dangerous consequences for
me for my family and for my people this
shouldn't be so hard okay that of course
is exactly right that's representative
Ted Joyce a Democrat from Florida who is
saying exactly the right thing now
Deutsch and his colleagues have been
attacked by people like Alexandra Ocasio
Cortez and Ilhan Omar and Rasheeda Talib
for having the audacity
to say the truth about Ilhan Omar
they've been they've been attacked
they've been they've been suggested that
they are trying to shut down debate and
all the 2020 leading Democratic
candidates have come out in favor of
Ilhan Omar most strongly of course
Bernie Sanders which is of most use to
members of the left who want to claim
that this isn't anti-semitic they point
to Bernie Sanders they swap Bernie
Greenlight's I mean Bernie's Jewish okay
Bernie Sanders has about as much
connection to a - to the Jewish
community as a ham sandwich meaning he
was born Jewish he is an overt atheist
he's a radically anti-israel socialist
like where exactly is his deep
connection to Judaism it doesn't exist
but he is convenience used because of
course he is ethnically Jewish so that
allows people to use him as cover in any
case representative Lee Zeldin who
actually is Jewish he is the Republican
member of the House who is Jewish he
said I'm not going to vote for this
garbage resolution because this garbage
resolution is specifically designed to
to cover up for L hen Omar being an
anti-semite we are here today right now
because of anti-semitic rhetoric from
one member of this chamber said again
and again and again if that member was a
Republican that members name would be in
this resolution and this resolution
would be all about condemning
anti-semitism and it would be done so
forcefully I apparently am giving rep
Omar more credit than the speaker is
because I don't believe she is naive I
believe that she knows exactly what
she's doing
anti-semitism must be condemned
unequivocally and emphatically support
of Israel support of Jews stand against
anti-semitism has been bipartisan in the
past it should be bipartisan today and
should be bipartisan for every moment in
the future hey everything that he says
is right and of course representative
Zeldin is Jewish and not only Jewish he
is pro-israel he has deep connections
with the Jewish community so he votes
against this resolution as do 22 other
Republicans and those same 23
Republicans who voted against that
resolution voted in favor of resolution
back in January to condemn white
supremacism right so this is not about
them humbly siding with white supremacy
that's a lie the reason that Republicans
didn't vote a few Republicans didn't
vote for the resolution yesterday
is because they didn't want to grant
cover to Ilhan Omar it is that simple
but that's not how the media played it
that's not how the media played it the
way the media played it they said that
the Republicans didn't vote for this
resolution covering for anti-semitism
because the Republicans are the real
anti-semites so notice the insane gas
lighting here a democratic
representative a fresh face on the cover
of Rolling Stone magazine so fresh so
faced with aoc with Nancy Pelosi that
fresh face is a blatant brutal
anti-semite a Jew hater and the house
won't condemn her House Democrats won't
condemn her and then they brought in a
basic resolution condemning
anti-semitism into a wishy-washy
resolution condemning everything except
for apparently radical Muslim
anti-semitism they won't condemn that
the only thing that they will condemn is
everything else everything else will be
condemned but they will exempt Ilhan
Omar and then some Republicans hey
listen I'm not gonna vote for that for
that ridiculous resolution you're
putting forward that is specifically
designed to cover for anti cemetery that
and the media's take all Republicans
won't vote for an anti hate resolution
who's hateful now Republicans this is so
wildly intellectually dishonest it is
such incredible gas lighting and the
media are complicit in it there because
all they honest-to-god these people are
just a knob refers for the radical left
Michael Barbaro of the New York Times
you host the daily he tweeted out so far
14 House Republicans have voted against
a bill condemning anti-semitism
anti-muslim another hatred wow this is
going to be hard to explain is it I just
explained it in less than 15 seconds
it's really not hard to explain when you
pass a stupid resolution designed to
cover for anti-semites by watering it
down until it is anodyne when people
vote against that they're not voting in
favor of anti-semitism they're voting
against watering down resolutions
against anti-semitism in order to cover
for Democrats but not for Michael Barbra
of the New York Times oh look at that
now who's the anti-semite Republicans
it's not just Michael barber Oh Jake
Sherman of Politico tweeted this out I
called them on it and then he tried to
back down he tweeted out House Democrats
have been under pressure for a week on
anti-semitism but House Republicans have
bailed them out hazard
publicans have bailed them out on
anti-semitism number three House
Representative Liz Cheney Lee Zeldin and
Louie Gohmert vote no Jeff Duncan
presents an embarrassing moment for
House GOP really it's an embarrassing
moment for Republicans when they refused
to go along with your cover-up for
anti-semitism go back to that tweet for
a second the people he mentions there
Lee's Elton a Jew Louis Louie Gohmert
the representative from Texas is the
most Philo sematic member of the House I
personally know that's insane
representative Liz Cheney herself put
out a statement explaining why she voted
like this quote today's resolution vote
was a sham put forward by Democrats to
avoid condemning one of their own and
denouncing violence hi semitism while I
stand wholeheartedly against
discrimination outlined in this
resolution the language before the House
today did not address the issue that is
front and center representative
Omar's comments were wrong and she has
proven multiple times she embodies a
vile hate-filled anti-semitic
anti-israel bigotry she deserves to be
rebuked by name and removed from the
House Foreign Affairs Committee so there
is no mistake about the values and
priorities that the house stands for for
democratic leadership to kowtow to their
radical members and refused to offer
legislative language that criticizes
representative Omar statements in the
strongest possible manner confirms what
we already knew that their party is
controlled by far left extremists who
can't even muster the courage to stand
up to blatant anti-semitism
that's why Liz Cheney voted against the
resolution but the media say oh no she
did it cuz really secretly she's the
anti-semite see if you don't go along
with the cover-up that means that you're
the real anti-semite and the media go
along with that Politico New York Times
and not just them not just them you'll
see how they are stenographers for aoc
and her radical crew in just a second
first let's talk about the window
coverings in your house window
treatments is one of those terms that
you don't think about all that much
because hey why would you but if you
look around your house and you realize
that it doesn't look that great the
reason is because your window coverings
stink instead you need some good stuff
from blinds comm lines nikon makes it
really easy for you not sure what you
want even where to start with blinds
calm you get a free online design
consultation just send them pictures of
your house they send back custom
recommendations from a professional from
what will work with your color scheme
furniture and specific rooms they'll
even send you free samples to make sure
everything looks as good in person
as it does online and every order gets
free shipping and here's the best part
if you accidentally miss measure or pick
the wrong color if you make a mistake
blinds.com will remake your blinds for
free they've made it really easy for you
so there's no excuse to leave up those
mangled blinds that make your place look
like a set from the wire and for a
limited time get 20% off everything at
blinds comm when you use promo code Ben
that is blinds.com promo code Ben for
20% off everything for wood blinds
cellular shades roller shades and more
as blinds.com promo code Ben rules and
restrictions to apply blinds comm
promoter Ben for 20% off everything ok
so as you see members of the media
taking dictation taking dictation from
AOC and I'll prove it to you here is
what a OC had to say about this here's
what she tweeted out this would be 20
quote where's the outrage over the 23
GOP members who voted no on a resolution
condemning bigotry today oh there's none
did they get called out raked over
ambushed in halls and relentlessly asked
why not no okay got it this is so
insanely to sound spreadsheet look she's
she's a damn liar AOC she's been a liar
since she was running and now she's even
more of a liar everybody knows what
happened here
AOC provided active cover for an open
anti-semite and now she's saying the
people who didn't help her provide that
cover are the real anti-semites who
they're the real anti-semites not you
who provided cover every step of the way
for the jeremy corbyn ization of your
party you who bragged two weeks ago you
were on the phone with vicious brutal
pro terror anti-semite Jeremy Corbyn two
freaking weeks ago you who have
campaigned with Linda Sarsour we're
supposed to pretend that you are
standing up to anti-semitism and the
people who stood up to you are the real
anti-semites
this is sheer absolute unmitigated
garbage and the media have been
repeating it at every turn because the
media are stenographers for Democrats
end of story
it's shocking it really is and for those
who believe that there was a real
genuine effort to fight anti-semitism
yesterday by the Democrats I present to
you ill Hannah Omar's response to all of
this first of all
Omar actually went out and was hugging
people on the House floor yesterday
after this resolution passed why not she
defeated Nancy Pelosi
but then she released a statement and
here was her statement
that was released alongside Rasheeda
Talib another anti-semite and Andre
Carson of Indiana who is also a Muslim
but I've no evidence he's an anti-semite
they issued the following statement
after the House voted overwhelmingly to
condemn all kinds of hate quote today is
historic on many fronts it's the first
time we have voted on a resolution
condemning anti-muslim bigotry in our
nation's history anti-muslim crimes have
increased 99 percent from 2014 to 2016
and are still on the rise are you
getting this are you getting this Ilhan
omar said anti-semitic stuff and today
is celebrating a resolution to condemn
Islamophobia you reading this then she
gets anti-semitism what does she say we
are tremendously proud to be part of a
body that has put forth a condemnation
of all forms of bigotry including
anti-semitism racism and white supremacy
at a time when extremism is on the rise
we must explicitly denounce religious
intolerance of all kinds and acknowledge
the pain felt by all communities our
nation is having a difficult
conversation and we believe this is
great progress so this is the code now
difficult conversation is I say
something blatantly anti-semitic
and then we cover for me that's what
that's nice hey that's a conversation
guys that's what el Han Omar says and
you can tell that Ilhan Omar is real
sorry about all of her anti-semitism
yesterday she retweeted a particular
tweet by a guy named Mehdi Hasan Mehdi
Hasan tweeted something out about Megan
McCain so we have to reverse course
Megan McCain was on the view Megan
McCain does an excellent job on the view
of representing decency and conservatism
so yesterday she was talking about
anti-semitism being glossed over by the
Democrats and she got emotional here's
what it sounded like the idea that this
is politicized I'm really not I was very
nervous to talk about this on this show
because I thought it would become
politicized and it really shouldn't be
on both sides it should be called out
and just because I don't technically
have Jewish family that are blood
related to me it doesn't mean I don't
take this as seriously and it is very
dangerous very dangerous and I think we
all collectively as Americans on both
sides and what ill on home art is saying
it's very scary to me and it's very
scary to a lot of people and I don't
think you have to be Jewish to recognize
your job of course she is exactly right
so what did Ilhan Omar do then what's so
offensive about what she said she said
Ilhan Omar's comments are anti-semitic
and anti-semitism is bad so Mehdi Hasan
he is a columnist for al-jazeera he's
economist for the intercept which is a
wild radical left publication that is
supremely anti-israel and is quite
friendly with anti-semitism
he's a host on al Jazeera English he
tweeted out quote Megan's late father
literally saying bomb bomb bomb bomb
bomb Iran
and insisted on referring to his
Vietnamese captors as gooks he also lest
we forget gave the world Sarah Palin so
a little less faux outrage over a former
refugee turned freshman representative
please so this al-jazeera hosts response
is not that ill hen Omar isn't
anti-semitic it's that Megan McCain ins
dad is a bad guy so Megan McCain should
shut up about anti-semitism and who
retweeted that o Ilhan Omar retweeted
that of course because she is not in the
slightest embarrassed or upset by her
anti-semitism she's quite happy about it
and why shouldn't she be happy about it
the entire Democratic Party just caved
and covered for her why shouldn't she be
overjoyed at the treatment that she has
just received we know who's in the
driver's seat now and it's the
anti-semite and by the way let's not
pretend that this has nothing to do with
with anti-semitism when it comes to when
it comes to Ilhan Omar's comments UI
Valley is another radical left
cartoonist sometimes I believe he's
associated with some of the folks at the
intercept and Eli Valli put out this
cartoon you should subscribe so you can
actually see what the cartoon looks like
it is straight from the pages of der
stürmer it is a Nazi cartoon hey Eli
Valli puts out a cartoon and it shows
Meghan McCain wearing a cross necklace
and in one hand she has a box of matzo
ball soup mix and he makes her look of
course hideous and and overweight and
all of this and in the other hand she
has a Jewish star marked you'd like udin
as in like the Nazi yellow star and and
then she has on the table in front of
her a copy of Yentl and a book called
jewish race explained and says the
things she said about the holy land that
refugee girls wants to exterminate us
Jews I mean this is straight up it is
straight up Jew hatred and the attempt
to suggest that Meghan McCain doesn't
know what she's talking about because
she's not Jewish and therefore she
shouldn't care about anti-semitism like
the radical left is fine with
anti-semitism they're not just fine with
it they are enthused
gastic about anti-semitism they're
supremely enthusiastic about
anti-semitism in fact and and it's
obvious that they are they've been
tolerating Linda Sarsour in their miss
Tyler is celebrating Linda Sarsour
yesterday Linda Sarsour was asked if
Israel has a right to exist now there's
a lot of anti-israel criticism criticism
of Israel policy that is not
anti-semitic saying that Israel has no
right to exist that's actually
anti-semitic a lot of anti-israel
commentary not anti-semitic Israel has
no right to exist anti-semitic that
means the wiping out of some six million
Jews in the Middle East and supplanting
it with a radical Islamics it's
dictatorship hey that is what people
like Linda Sarsour would like so Linda
Sarsour was asked specifically about
this and I'll show you her response and
the response of her bodyguards in just a
minute but first let's talk about hiring
hiren can be challenging but there's one
place you can go where a hiring is
simple fast and smart a place where
growing businesses connect to qualified
candidates that place is zip recruiters
calm slash Daily wire zip recruiter
sends your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience and then invites them to
apply to your job as applications come
in zip recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you're
never gonna miss a great match zip
recruiter is so effective that 80% of
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the site
within the very first day right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that is
zip recruiter comm slash at Dai ly w ir
e zip recruiter comm slash daily wire
zip recur is indeed the smartest way to
hire go check them out for free and
gamete rise zipper critter comm slash
daily where there's a reason we use zip
recruiter here at the daily wear offices
to make sure that we find the best
employees quickly zip recruiter is the
smartest way to hire all righty so Linda
Sarsour is good proof of just where the
Democratic Party now stands what they
are willing to stand for so here was
Linda Sarsour yesterday being asked
whether the State of Israel has a right
to exist and then wait till you hear
what her bodyguards have to say to
people asking her the question do you
believe the State of Israel has a right
to exist we'll answer questions later
after the press conference I'll be happy
to answer that
don't take questions
Linda do you believe the nation exists
do you believe that they should this
draws the right to exist why you
blocking me sir why are you blocking
before these guys are joining me Linda
we are currently she's ignoring me why
are you guys pushing New Year's she said
questions why are you here how much do
you get paid how much do you get paid
you work for Israel that's just a
reporter asking Linda Sarsour if she
believes the State of Israel should
exist Linda Sarsour is very close with
Helen Omar and AOC and the rest of the
Democratic leadership she campaigned for
Kirsten Gillibrand don't tell me the
Democratic Party isn't comfortable with
anti-semitism they are embracing it with
both arms not one arm both arms it's
it's absolutely incredible by the way
and then the media again are playing our
playing stenographer for the Democrats
to this point David Duke came out
yesterday and he said that Ilhan Omar is
deeply important he tweeted out a photo
of Ilhan Omar a Somali woman of Muslim
descent with in a love emoji saying by
defiance to the Zionist occupied
government
Ilhan Omar is now the most important
member of the US Congress
so David Duke tweets out now I'm old
enough to remember when president
Trump's failure to condemn David Duke in
the 2016 election led to a million
headlines how many headlines have there
been about David Duke embracing Johan
tomorrow or Andrew Anglin the head of
the daily stormer the neo-nazi newspaper
embracing Ilhan Omar how many headlines
have there been about that how much is
CNN covered that and I don't want to
hear that David Duke is now irrelevant
if he's irrelevant now he was irrelevant
two years ago so you're gonna have to
explain to me why he's not relevant
as soon as Democrats get embraced by
David Duke and Richard Spencer by the
way loves Ilhan Omar there's no hiding
of the ball here everybody knows what is
going on but the media are lying about
it and they're facilitating the lie and
it's absolutely horrifying now what
exactly is going to be the outcome of
all of this well it's pretty obvious
that the Democratic Party has been taken
over by the radicals and as I've been
saying for the past several days the
Democratic Party may not be fully
anti-semitic but they are happy to
embrace anti-semitism
if it
means that they get to make common cause
with the radical socialist base that's
what's going on here that's why Bernie
Sanders was first out of the gates
defending Ilhan Omar that's the real
story so president Trump comes out today
and he is talking about this resolution
and he says that he thought it was
disgraceful and then he characterizes
the Democratic Party because it's become
the Democrats have become an anti-israel
party they've become an anti Jewish
party and I thought that vote was a
disgrace and so does everybody else if
you get an honest answer if you get an
honest answer from politicians they
thought it was a disgrace the Democrats
have become an anti-israel party they've
become an anti Jewish party and that's
too bad
okay there is no question that what he
is saying is correct I mean that is just
correct now you can rip on Trump all you
want but forget about who's saying it is
it has the Democratic Party become
anti-israel there's no question they
have they became anti-israel under the
auspices of Barack Obama who is a
radically anti-israel president a man
who helped lie to the American people
helped lie promulgated a massive lie to
the American people in order to push
forward in Iran ziyal that in dangers
the State of Israel a man who allowed
anti-israel resolutions to go forward at
the UN Security Council a man who
attempted to block Defense Department
aid to Israel in the middle of the Gaza
war in 2014
Barack Obama was radically anti-israel
his administration was radically
anti-israel there's just there's no
other way to put that and as far as them
being an anti Jewish party they just
proved it yesterday I mean that they
proved it on the floor of the house so
everybody's gonna say oh well Trump in
Charlottesville and David Duke and I was
fine say oh that's true say the
president Trump said some really bad
stuff a couple of years ago that he made
common cause with anti-semites or at
least was silent toward them are winton
not into them in 2015 2016 and into 2017
say all those things the democratic
party the approval of Israel inside the
Democratic Party is at all-time lows it
is well below 50% in the Republican
Party it is up near 80 percent and when
it comes to the anti-jewish nature of
the parties there is no question which
party has full-scale embraced in
anti-jewish perspective and that is the
demo
at a party a president Trump got
shellacked by the vast majority of
elected Republicans after
charlottesville he got killed during the
primaries by people like me I'm waiting
to hear Democrats come forth and condemn
me ohon Omar
they couldn't even do it in a vote the
entire party infrastructure was just
taken over by the anti-semites so forget
whatever you think about Trump because
that's not the question today the
question is what's happening with the
Democratic Party we can condemn
anti-semitism wherever it comes from
unless you're a Democrat then you only
condemn anti-semitism if it's white
supremacists he started from Paul
Krugman yesterday who said he's only
scared of right-wing anti-semitism you
know ask the Jews in the Middle East ask
the Jews in Europe ask the Jews who are
being beaten on the streets of Brooklyn
not by white supremacists but by members
of the intersectional coalition ask them
which type of anti-semitism is dangerous
the answer is all but it is the left
that is openly embracing anti-semitism
and allowing it to guys itself as just
mere anti-israel talk it's sure nonsense
now this all has consequences
by the way ill gente Mar completely
unrepentant today she she was profiled
by Politico she said I am certainly not
looking to be comfortable I don't want
everyone necessarily to feel comfortable
around me I think really the most
exciting things happen when people are
extremely uncomfortable
yes making the Jews uncomfortable
everyday illaha no mark and then you
have a Nipomo a porter for Politico
saying I've heard this from more than
one freshman Democrat when asked about
Omar's comfort comments they use the
word uncomfortable often need for those
types of conversations so Democrats are
now saying anti-semitism let's have a
conversation let's have a conversation
and then Politico has another story out
today about how Bernie Sanders raced to
support Ilhan Omar knowing that a lot of
people on the Left would be very happy
with an ethnic Jews defending Ilhan Omar
mat continent has met continent the
editor of the Washington free beacon has
a really good piece out today he says if
anti-semitism is the price of a
socialist America so be it
obviously that is true obviously that is
Trinette we'll get to what this means
for the future of the Democratic Party
in just one second first you're gonna
have to go over to Daley wire.com and
subscribe go subscribe right now over at
daily where come get the rest of our
show live for $9.99 a month then you can
also get two hours
additionally in the afternoon we're
having on representative Lee Zeldin a
little bit later today to talk about
this ridiculous resolution also when
when you spend ninety nine bucks a year
you get the leftist tears tumblr this
world famous leftist cheers tumblr today
we are featuring a daily where premium
subscriber we wanted to give a shout out
to a different subscriber every week as
a thank you for helping support the
daily wire because who wouldn't want to
get a shout out when the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in America
this week's shout-out goes to Nathan at
town and it's T o n n 85 on Twitter
Nathan is flying high in the sky while
sipping those leftist tears still hot at
that great altitude
Nathan excellent shot of the tumbler
thanks for being a subscriber if you
want to receive one of the most amazing
shout outs you've ever experienced make
your life worthwhile right here on the
bench Shapiro show you have to be an
annual subscriber you have to post a
photo of your tumblr on either twitter
or instagram with the hashtag leftist
tears tumblr you can even be in the
photo if you'd like or you don't have to
be just send us those photos so go check
us out subscribe you get the rest of the
show live also we have a great Sunday
special coming up this week with Arthur
Brooks an American Enterprise Institute
when you subscribe you get that a day
early on Saturday
we're always upgrading our content we
answer questions during the during the
breaks of our radio show sometimes so
lots of stuff going on when you
subscribe go check us out also a YouTube
iTunes leave us a review we always
appreciate it we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in America
[Music]
so what are the consequences for Nancy
Pelosi having handed over control of her
party to AOC and Ilhan Omar and Rasheeda
Talib and the anti-semites and enablers
who are the fresh faces of the
Democratic Congress so fresh so phase
Politico has a piece today here's what
they say they have gathered in defiance
of the freezing temperatures on a late
February night scores with them twirling
Somali flags in one hand and American
flags in the other crowding the arrivals
terminal and waiting to welcome one of
their own the vast Somali community in
the Twin Cities is like one sprawling
extended family explains ali aden a 39
year old engineer who came to the u.s.
two decades ago as we survey the scene
when a prominent member of the family
arrives it's customary to greet them
this way
is it congresswoman Omar they're waiting
for I asked representing the freshman
Democrat whose district we're standing
in Ilhan he smiles broadly no no if it
were ill hen the whole city would be
here instead it was just to meet some
obscure Somali dignitary but Omar is a
rock star in her district in her
district also she's on Rolling Stone so
I guess Democrats are trying to make
this anti-semite in actual rock star
Omar was destined to stand out after
Congress changed its 181 year olds rule
prohibiting headward to accommodate her
she became the first person to wear a
hijab on the House floor but it wasn't
her wardrobe or her religion or her
gripping biography as congresswoman who
came of age in a refugee camp that
distinguished Omar in her early days on
Capitol Hill rather it was her usage of
social media and the uproar that ensued
and then talks about her anti-semitic
comments and then she talks about what
exactly then she talks about what
exactly her perspective is and her
perspective is that they need to make
Jews uncomfortable and they also need to
move in a incredibly socialist direction
Omar says I'm certainly not looking to
be comfortable I don't want to make
everyone necessarily feel comfortable
around me I think the most exciting
things happen when people are extremely
uncomfortable and then she says this is
the best part of it she starts ripping
on Barack Obama and she says that Barack
Obama was a problem she says the hope
and change offered by Barack Obama was a
mirage recalling the caging of kids at
the us-mexico border and the droning of
countries around the world on Obama's
watch she argues that the Democratic
President operated within the same fun
mentally broken framework as his
Republican successor we can't only be
upset with Trump his policies are bad
but many of the people who came before
him also had really bad policies they
just were more polish than he was Omar
says and that's not what we should be
looking for anymore we don't want
anybody to get away with murder because
they are polished we want to recognize
the actual policies that are behind the
pretty face and the smile so she is
ripping on Barack Obama and she wants a
socialist takeover of the Democratic
Congress she says I don't believe that
tiptoeing is the way to win the hearts
and minds of the people I get saddened
by some of my freshmen colleagues who
can't understand that within their
districts the idea of Medicare for all
is extremely popular the green New Deal
is a very popular idea in their
districts making sure that we have a
final fix to our broken immigration
system is very popular in their
districts what they pay attention to is
the rhetoric that says this is a red to
blue district you have to be careful you
can't talk about these policies well in
reality these people are like everyone
else they struggle with the cost of
health care they struggle with our
broken infrastructure they struggle with
having an economy that brings them into
the 21st century and we have to be
willing to have those conversations
facing another round of denunciations
Omar refused to back down this is all
Politico kissing her ear what ensued was
a week of unmitigated chaos within House
Democratic ranks senior Democrats pushed
for a vote on a resolution condemning
anti-semitism younger Democrats rallied
behind Omar and objected to her being
singled out and the party's leadership
desperate to defuse the situation
finally settled on a catch-all version
of the resolution condemning all forms
of hate speech including against Native
Americans and Pacific Islanders it was a
clear-cut victory for Omar and her
allies on the left in a preview of her
defiance just hours before the
videotaped comments thrust the
congresswoman back into the national
limelight Omar told me that Washington
should get used to her troublemaking as
much as other people are uncomfortable
I'm excited about the change in tone
that has taken place that is extremely
positive she says and my ability I think
to agitate our foreign policy
discussions in a way that many of my
colleagues who have been anti
intervention anti-war have been unable
to do in the past so I'm okay with
taking the blows if it means it will
ignite conversations that no one was
willing to have before I you see she's
just igniting conversations that's all
that's happening it's not that she's a
radical anti-semite who was open about
her anti-semitism she's she's igniting
conversations well Nancy Pelosi gets to
own this crap now Nancy you own this you
decided to surrender your
to these people you bought the ticket
now you take the ride you wanted a
Bernie Sanders LED party you got it lady
you made this happen you decided to
surrender your party to the
intersectional socialist mix and Bernie
Sanders decided to surrender his
socialism to the intersectional
contingent in the hopes that they would
support him in the presidential race
Bernie Sanders there is no question is
the frontrunner for the Democratic
nomination at this point why because he
is willing to pander to the
intersectional base while being overtly
socialist there's a reason that Bernie
Sanders came out he knows better and
decided to openly embrace the
anti-semitic members of his own
contingent and to pretend that their
anti-semitism was just an anti-israel
rhetoric make no mistake the Democratic
Left knows exactly what it's doing and
now it's gonna get it good and hard they
voted for us they're gonna get a good
and hard because if you think the
American people stands with the
Democratic Party in their willingness to
embrace anti-semitism this way you got
another thing coming if you think the
American people are interested in
embracing socialism and radical
anti-semitism and that's going to be
your platform you got another thing
coming guys and you may think you can
get away with it cuz Trump is unpopular
but here's the important thing to
remember President Trump is going to run
against someone it's not just gonna be a
referendum on Trump it's gonna be a
referendum on how radical Democrats
decide to be the American people do not
agree with this stuff I still have
enough confidence in the American people
to believe that they hate anti-semitism
and that they are appalled by what they
saw yesterday from the Democrats and
that they are appalled by Ilhan Omar
statements that they are appalled by the
radical socialism that is being pressed
forward with the support of an
intersectional coalition rooted in a
hatred of America's hierarchical system
that's the contention of
intersectionality America has a
hierarchical system and we know it's we
need a band together to wreck it most
Americans don't believe that most
Americans are not willing to be
separated into groups this way and then
targeted by a group if you don't fall
inside the intersectional coalition how
would a sad moment for the country
seriously I'm not somebody who puts a
lot of faith in the Democratic Party to
do the right thing as you know but it's
a sad moment for the country I didn't
think it would come to this I really
didn't not this quickly anyway there
were early indicators the Democratic
Party was going to move in an
anti-semitic direction
I mean obviously they've been tolerating
louis farrakhan for years Barack Obama
sat in Jeremiah Wright's church for 20
years but the full-scale embrace that
was something I was not expecting and I
don't think many people were
alright time for some questions in the
mailbag so let's see Stephen says hey
bud my question is something I'm
supposed to do for school I'm supposed
to ask multiple people the definition of
what rhetoric is to help form my own can
you tell me how you would define
rhetoric thanks huge fan well I mean
rhetoric I think is argumentative style
it is it is the choice of whether to use
emotion or logic in a particular
argument how you reach out to people now
that's how I would define rhetoric and
it can be good it can be bad but I think
the way you express arguments is very
clearly linked to how convincing those
arguments are Christian says hi Ben I'm
an eighteen year old with a DD I want to
read books but whenever I try to read my
mind will linger and I don't comprehend
what I am reading and or will get very
bored very fast do you have any advice
for getting in the habit of reading and
focusing well reading well you know I'll
tell you that for me listening to
audiobooks sometimes helps me
concentrate more I don't know if you may
be more of an an aural learner meaning a
URL like a person who learns via
listening if you listen to this podcast
for example it's basically a firehose of
information you may get the same thing
from audio listening to books or if you
really want to slow down and comprehend
what you are reading
I would suggest a couple of things one
is you can read some of the parts out
loud to is something that I've started
to do I never used to underline in my
books because I don't like defacing
books I sort of treat books with
reverence but one of the things I've
started to do also because I can do it
on Sabbath is I get those little tabs
that allow you to sort of tab a certain
page a little stickies and I use them
when I'm reading and that helps me focus
in because just the mirror action of
having to focus in on what I wanted to
AB allows me to concentrate a little bit
better daniel says do you think the
increase in radical left-wing activity
in the Democratic Party is going to
create an increase in radical right-wing
activity as a council reaction from the
Republicans well I I do think that there
is always the fact that people in
response to bad coalition's tend to form
bad coalition's and I think it's one of
the reasons the president Trump went and
nodded at the alt-right in 2016 and so
many people were willing to go along
with that I think it was because he was
suggesting that the end
the world was nice oh you make common
cause with the people who are willing to
make common cause with you no matter how
vile so that would not be surprising to
me in fact I think that we've already
seen that I think the Democrats because
they are polarized by President Trump
have decided they're going to go as far
left as they can and embrace the most
radical segments of their own base as we
segment ourselves off societally and as
we see the other side increasingly as
the enemy this this thing turns into a
spiral of hatred that's gonna get worse
i think rachel says greetings ben i have
to write a paper for my class forming an
argument either for or against keeping
the electoral college which side would
you take and why well i'm in favor of
keeping the electoral college because I
do think that states matter the entire
bargain of the electoral college was
that the popular vote was not sufficient
you don't want the entire presidency
simply being decided by people who live
in New York City and Los Angeles you
would prefer that people in Montana have
a say and I know there are a lot of
people who say well you know that's
that's really bad the Senate is the same
thing we've seen this call from
Democrats now the Senate is a terrible
place because it's non representative
the original bargain of the United
States is a federalist system not a full
on not a full on democracy not an
American democracy a federalist system
where states and the federal government
split Authority and the states have a
share in deciding how federal authority
is allocated that's the argument in
favor of the Electoral College and then
says if AOC runs for president in 2024
would you run for president just to get
that debate with her Schapiro 2024 if
AOC ran for president and 20 listen to
get me to run for president I think
would be would be a heavy lift it seems
like a terrible job and campaigning all
the time seems quite awful but honestly
if I felt it was the best way to help
the country I would do it Philip says
hey Ben I very much like the idea of a
convention of states what amendments
would you propose to curb the abuse of
power by the federal government what
could be added to protect the
Constitution from the branches running
over at roughshod thanks Philip well I
think first of all one of the great
things about a convention of states is
that it real way khun's and
reinvigorates people's interest in the
constitution in the end the Constitution
is a set of parchment barriers if the
American people are not willing to stand
up if the if the American people are not
willing to stand up to violations of the
Constitution then they're going to allow
the Constitution to be undercut
obviously as far as amendments I would
like to see I've said before I would
like to see an amendment that forces all
Congressional pieces of legislation to
be shorter than 10 pages in plain
language I'd like to see them beyond
single topics no more omnibus packages I
would like to see the the abolition of
departments of government from the
executive branch because the executive
branch simply has too much power
administrative government should end
that's where I would start trevor says
hey Ben where do you see the Democratic
Party going with respect to their
increased radicalism and if they lose in
2020 do you think they'll triple down on
their radical views love the show thanks
yeah absolutely I mean once you go
radical you rarely go back there's
really a turn back to moderation after
you go completely radical now if they
get shellac if they get destroyed then
you might see sort of a Jimmy Carter
response to George McGovern from 1972 to
1976 the Democrats saying listen we've
gone too far we've lost the American
people but given that the American
electorate is already so closely divided
I don't think that's going to happen I
think they're gonna move increasingly in
a radical direction Nathan says hey Ben
I'm a new subscriber I've been a big fan
of your show for almost two years how
many books would you say you own do we
get to see a tour of your library also
what are you some of your favorite books
that you own well I have last count
5,000 books something like that
basically every place in my house is
covered with books in fact I've been
reading Marie Kondo and I'm thinking
about going and giving away some of the
books that I'm not going to reread and
that makes me sad because I love books
so much some of my favorite books well I
have some signed copies of books I have
a signed copy of Charles Krauthammer
book I have a signed copy of the Tom
Wolf's book I have I have some you know
at Churchill books obviously I have an
old set of his history of world war ii
and then just in terms of books that I
love the Federalist Papers I refer to
often obviously Alexis de Tocqueville I
refer to quite often I have the full
papers of Abraham Lincoln refer to that
a lot and then of course I have my
Jewish books my room so that would be
the Tanakh the the Torah and the
prophets and the writings I refer to
that a lot I have a lot of books and I
love all of them honestly I feel more
comfortable surrounded by books when I
was in law school and I was lonely I
went out to bookstores and I bought
books and I surrounded myself with books
and honestly it made me feel emotionally
better to be surrounded by great
thinkers and be able to essentially
converse with them across the centuries
david says do you think an increasingly
anti-semitic platform from the
democratic
party may lead to an increase of
American Jewish immigration to Israel in
the near future well yeah I mean I do I
think that you've seen this in Europe I
think that well you've seen in Europe is
he as anti-semitism is increased people
are leaving France is seeing a
year-over-year decrease in the Jewish
population because so many families are
leaving and moving to Israel if it turns
out that America moves in the same
direction why exactly what American Jews
stay in danger and not move somewhere
else if it turns out they have nowhere
else to go so yeah I do think that
you'll see more Jews making a Lea let's
see
Chris says dear Ben I've always had the
personal goal of attending an Ivy League
school based on your experiences at both
Harvard and UCLA is there a major
difference between the two with regard
to opportunity I feel as if the only
surefire way to have significant
influence in academia politics etc is to
attend one of these schools thank you
well there's no question that
credentialing matters an awful lot to
folks because we're not allowed to take
IQ tests publicly and we're not allowed
to to grade people on the basis of those
sorts of tests and so what people tend
to do is they use degree as a stand-in
for intelligence so someone graduated
from Harvard then we sort of assumed
they're smarter than somebody who
graduated from the local junior college
for example which sometimes it's true
and sometimes it's not actually and in
terms of practical knowledge very often
is not with that said you know I believe
that that going to Harvard is a
significant advantage it does create
social networks that allow you to to
take advantage of people that you know
there's a great book by what is named JD
Vance hillbilly elegy where he talks
about moving from sort of Appalachia to
Yale Law School and how that changed his
life there's no question social networks
matter and Jessie says hey Ben what are
your thoughts on the massive Bryce
Harper Manny Machado contracts I know
the White Sox were at least in on
Machado during the offseason well I mean
my thought is that they got what they
felt they could get in the market I
wouldn't a signed a contract for that
much with these guys particularly not
Machado I mean at least Bryce Harper has
a track record of production and he
doesn't have as much of an attitude
problem
Machado wouldn't even run out ground
balls with the Dodgers so that to me is
a massive red flag Clinton says dear
future president Shapiro as of today I'm
now you're long subscribe but partly
because I wanted to pose this question
to you in light of recent events
involving anti summit
in fresh faces can you help clarify as
to why there are so many people out
there who believe Israel is land stolen
from Palestinians additionally can you
point to me two more evidence as to how
or why Palestine is linked to terror
organizations that push to oppress the
Jewish state admittedly I don't know
much about the conflicts in Israel or
their origins and I think this is true
for everyday Americans thus making it
difficult for them to condemn recent
anti-semitism especially with the media
muddying the waters thanks for all you
do a lot of people believe Israel is
land stolen from Palestinians because
they don't know their history Israel is
the historic Jewish homeland the only
reason anyone cares about it is because
the Jews were there first there's been
continuous Jewish presence in Israel for
legitimately three millennia and the
notion that Israel stole land that Jews
have been living on forever
is absolutely asinine and ridiculous the
British Mandate limited Jewish
immigration into British Palestine they
tried to prevent us from moving in Jews
were discriminated against and massacred
in places like Hebron in 1929 long
before there was a Jewish state there
there has never been an independent
Palestinian state in that region ever it
was under the auspices of the Ottoman
Empire it was under the auspices of the
British Mandate it was never there was
there just wasn't there was not an
independent Palestinian state in that
region there are lots of other states in
fact the term Palestinian used to refer
to Jew used to refer to it because every
Palestinian is if you go back to
regeneration Syrian or Egyptian or
Jordanian 70% of of Jordan is ethnically
Palestinian so there is a Palestinian
state already it exists in Jordan if you
want another two-state solution one that
was rejected by the Palestinians in and
all the Arab nations by the way in 1948
748 if you want a second one you're
gonna have to have a government that
actually wants to negotiate and create a
peaceful situation instead Palestinians
have decided that the only solution is
the complete wholesale destruction of
the State of Israel that is part of the
Palestinian Authority mandate as part of
their Charter as part of the Hamas
charter the official government stance
of Israel's quote-unquote negotiations
negotiating partners is that Israel
ought to be destroyed that's not a
negotiating partner Israel's been
willing to make territorial concessions
repeatedly and has done so repeatedly
and it's weird because the Palestine
Liberation Organization supposedly
created to liberate Palestine was formed
in 1964 in 1964 guess who controlled the
West Bank and the Gaza Strip Egypt
control the Gaza Strip
Jordan controlled the West Bank the
so-called West Bank Anjaneya and Samaria
so why would you need to liberate
Palestine if who's already controlled by
Muslim countries the answer what they
mean by Palestine Liberation
Organization is exactly what Mark Lamont
Hill has said from the river to the sea
Palestine shall be free no State of
Israel destroyed the place kill kill as
many Jews as possible in the process ok
time and if you want a good resource on
this there's a really good book by eli
bard called mick myths in fact that in
very simple fashion goes through a lot
of the frequently asked questions about
the israel-palestinian conflict alright
time for some things that i like so
things i like today there's a great new
book out by Tim Carney of the Washington
Examiner and the American Enterprise
Institute it's called alienated America
why some places thrive while others
collapse and in it Timothy Carney talks
about why certain areas in the United
States seem to be doing well while
others seems to be doing very poorly and
he points out that the areas in the
United States that have the least social
cohesion tend to be the ones that voted
heavily for President Trump in for
example the Republican primaries the
people who feel dispossessed people who
feel that they that America is not what
it used to be that those people voted
for President Trump because President
Trump was was resonating to their
message and they were resonating to his
so what exactly is going on in these
areas
Timothy Carney goes through a factor by
factor he talks about the economic
effects of trade in certain areas as
opposed to overall he talks about the
economic effects of robot ization of
massive industries but mostly what he
talks about is the fact that all of the
units of social cohesion that used to
exist family church social institutions
have collapsed in a lot of areas of the
country and that if you actually want to
revitalize those areas of the country
it doesn't actually start at the factory
per se it's not a matter of economics
alone one certainly it is more a matter
of rebuilding these social institutions
and rebuilding the social fabric it's a
terrific book alienated America should
go out and purchase it right now it
actually echoes a lot of the same themes
that I hid in my new book that is coming
out and just about a week and a half
here on the the right side of history
you should go check out my book as well
but alienated America is a really
fantastic book by Timothy Connery it's a
it's an easy read and well written go
check that out
ok other things that I like so I have to
note a thing that I really like a person
that I really like so my producer send
you
unfortunately is moving on and she is
wonderful she is just horrific I can't
say enough wonderful things about Sonia
she is a kind generous human being she
deals with all of my falls on a daily
basis but more than that she is a warm
soul and I am so appreciative of the
time that she has spent with us here at
the Daily wire and on the Ben Shapiro
show she's just a terrific person and I
feel like we become good friends and so
I just want to wish her the best because
this is her last day of work here so
she's liberated she gets to go and do
something fun but we're definitely gonna
miss her so and Sonia is is the chief
thing human that I like today okay time
for a quick thing that I hate okay so
the thing that I hate today I talked
about a little bit yesterday on my radio
show but I on Presley is another one of
the fresh faces of Congress she's from
Massachusetts she's not gotten anywhere
near the attention of the other fresh
faces nonetheless she made an insane
ridiculous and silly proposal yesterday
she suggested that we lower the voting
age to 16 since the days of
abolitionists suffragists and civil
rights activists young people have been
pushing the wheels of progress forward
these youth our young people who will
inherit the nation we design here by
virtue of our policies or by default of
our policies and authority these very
same young people should also have a say
in who represents them for your
consideration
amendment number one to seven which
would lower the minimum voting age in
federal elections from 18 to 16 years of
age okay yeah good luck with that my
favorite thing about this is that she
went on to explain why 16 year-olds
should vote as many of them have jobs is
that gonna be a requirement now you have
to have a job to vote if that's the case
I'm fine with abolishing all limits on
age if you just have a job have to have
a job to vote man this is not gonna go
great for Democrats honestly but that's
not really what she means what she means
is that we should continue to expand the
voter base to a bunch of people who are
dependent on government largesse when
you're 16 years old you are still in a
public school and that means that your
teachers and your peers are going to
steer you how to vote all of this is
absolutely silly 16 year-olds are less
mature than they ever have been at any
time in human history 400 years ago
sixteen year olds were expected to move
out of the house and be married already
really and even 150 years ago sixteen
year olds were getting ready to move out
they are already apprentice in himself
they're already getting jobs they're
aren't getting ready to start a family
the average age of first marriage in the
United States even fifty years ago is
about 20 for both men and women now the
average age of marriage is about 73 in
the United States if you are at 26
you're still on your parents health
insurance program if anything we should
be raising the voting age and I'm
speaking as someone who's probably
qualified to vote when I was 16 since I
was already in college I would gladly
gladly have raised the voting age when I
was 25 who prevents other people who are
25 from voting particularly if they are
still living at home and reliant on
mommy and daddy's health insurance plan
alrighty well we will be back here later
to see out of two more hours we'll be
joined by representative Lee Zeldin of
New York he's one of the Republicans who
voted against the supposed faux
anti-hate resolution from the Democrats
he'll stop by to explain why you should
stop by too that's why you should
subscribe so you can actually listen to
those two hours if not we will see you
here for the Sunday special if you're
subscriber the Saturdays special then
we'll see you here again on Monday I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Adam sy events audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Joshua alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wired production copyright daily
wire 20 19